hello and welcome to this video playing
do icc so we gather I think I hate think
you place especially cough yeah we had
this in an earlier game time ago let's
see here the slide is not going to be
refuting / Nick off but it is very solid
for white so hmm do I take this now
probably another this even though it's
still very solid now it's very difficult
for black yet you do something active
but the same applies for wide not easy I
can pile up a little bit oh I think I'm
actually happy about that this is more
weakening than anything I could be wrong
could be wrong but I think before it's
more of a weakness than then an acid
would seem of course he I mean if you
would get to check my v3 form this is um
would be something for him but it's not
so easy to do I think it's easier for me
to get to his pawns on before 96 than it
is for him to get to play against be
three
so let's see two
let's see to what is he doing down
knight c6 Queen d6 route 28 c 5 root e6
a tick on be six min plus v2 much
it's interesting though c5 routine six
tix they are feeling I don't know and
maybe I should have played bishop f'nor
bishop f1 blunders before I am okay
otherwise bishop everyone would have
been interesting for see fire this is
actually helpful and now i can take the
60 no I cannot I can actually not take
okay
hmm it's bad it's bad I wanted to take
you really wanted to do that should be
several that's a funny idea
maybe look a form just looking for
hmm
not sure what is doing here I mean this
Bishop now looks off rather would want
to be on g2 I've got five out of five
against the device is he not a bad
school
so what's he up to it just gives the
porn up but okay if I take it he's got
night before so let's go back so that at
least f3 is not hanging like Knight f3 I
also wonder if creed III is actually a
move okay now this is this I can't take
the snow if ready for instant d3 keeping
the material Quincy six maybe yeah
Quincy six but ok I can go back home can
go back yeah surgeon named I cannot take
F Queen g5 though is an active active
kind of move and Queen a5 Queen 85 and
then I have night before I need to get
the Queen out of out of this oh um great
great great great so I have to play this
now ha it's really not good job not good
yeah from a from just a pawn up to this
now hmm not great
sc5 actually a movie tactics take 36
before this habits actually good well
completely coincidental tactic so night
if five you can take the Flavian here
this phone is probably rather more hi
morning other weaker it's not really
helping me
should a six or something
really I want to activate here k
probably i can get material here to
restore quality maybe maybe i can
actually no no it's not possible to do
anything he's getting a foreign check
check check it's even the roomba sugar
draw offered Graham are drawn hmm Jerry
that was a bit disappointing I thought I
was getting somewhere like here I should
have something at least a little bit Jim
let's probably not enough night III
interesting to a 5 mm yeah this is was a
somewhat unconventional idea where he is
he keeps things together of course I
totally blended looka heah so I have to
do this yeah I wasn't quite sure what
what I should do after this move ok I
can just take ok I can just take of
course it looks a little bit strange
this kind of situation but CMC doesn't
have anything right away um yeah then
this is good then this is just good
can't you're probably dealing with the
draw I could have taken when we find
here and here yeah maybe he had chances
there the pawn really looks like I could
be lost my computer doesn't see anything
completely convincing this one may be
forward to break it up that's probably a
draw with correct play yeah so there was
just as one chance that I had still felt
a for the strategic mistake weakening
weakening his position now maybe it is
in a way but it's not so so severe that
it should cost him the game or anything
ok guys thanks for watching